ample land and abundant coastline
highways hangars and houses it's easy to
see the potential of Roosevelt roads
right now in all this hemisphere there's
not a place with the infrastructure that
the Navy created on that eight thousand
acre property but on the ground it's a
ghost town when the Navy abandoned the
base ten years ago an estimated 300
million dollars a year vanished from the
island's economy a reuse plan stalled
for lack of private investors and public
funds the surrounding community of ceiba
has been devastated and I've gone away
out there after we lost the base we lost
many people who paid taxes so that
debilitated the economy a mistake is not
awarding the municipality enough money
to rehabilitate the city now after a
decade of decay the Puerto Rican
government feels it has a formula for
the revival of Roosevelt roads we want a
world-class developer to do something
with order with that plan a new master
plan for the site features zones for
hotels and entertainment sports and
recreation commerce and ecotourism
this month the local authority begins
taking proposals from developers to fill
out this blank canvas Rodrigo Veloso and
his partner Alex Brito have their
proposal ready to go the vision is a
city like compound with an entertainment
at its core there's going to be a total
redevelopment primarily around the
airport first and the ports then we're
gonna try to get some manufacturing some
universities and then we're going to
little by little start breathing life
into it the site's infrastructure and
location make it a convenient hub for
aviation two destinations near and far
and the possibilities for commercial
space travel have drawn interest from
Richard Branson who recently toured
Roosevelt roads with Puerto Rican
officials the government isn't shy about
touting the site to other world-class
investors and operators while funnies
like Disney is the only place in the
world that they can have their cruise
ships they can have an airport that
carries even b-52s and at the same time
have the land to the battle theme parks
acres of potential and intriguing goals
but the challenge is the same as it's
been for decades selecting a plan
attracting capital and moving the
project from opportunities to reality
are you ready to make this happen
yes and I promise the world I'm pretty
sure that you will not take 40 years to
make it happen in control